hello everyone and welcome to the finals
of the air things masters we have a game
that is truly remarkable it's uh
well it's been a while since we've had a
game like this especially uh in rapid
chess and uh the the two of them meet
again after the world chess championship
match uh this is the uh second game of
their match in the air things masters
first game was a nice one magnus said
the white pieces but it ended in a draw
uh but this one well
it's just best to dive just uh straight
into it as there is quite a lot to cover
so nepo with the white pieces opens with
e4 uh magnus goes for the sicilian
defense knights
we have c5 knight to f3 knight to c6 and
now bishop to b5 going for the rossulimo
anders medina attack
we have e6 by magnus and now uh nipple
castles and now this is a very tricky
knight to d4 move going after the bishop
here
which of course can be captured and then
you can double black spawns but this is
something that you can play of course in
rapid chests so knight capture c
captures uh and now c3 challenging the
central pawn here uh hoping that black
captures but of course that will not
happen with a6 by magnus bishop back to
d3 and now bishop to c5 uh we have b4
now challenging the bishop here bishop
back to a7 and now the position uh has
been reached before it was reached uh
last year in the beale masters open
between pablo diana and pragananda where
bishop the b2 was played elianov was
able to win that game but here mag
nipple plays knight to a3 and it is now
uh already as of move 9 that we have a
completely new game uh so let's see how
the game develops with knight today e7
preparing the castle knight to c2 now
forcing black to capture otherwise we're
just going to play c characters on d4
and have a
great pawn here so d captures in c3 uh
you could also consider a move like d5
but d5 is just everything gets traded
off and it's
nothing special here for example knight
captures bishop capture c captures d
capture z bishop captures and we can
castle here and white should always be
better here just a little bit um as
white does have the bishop pair you can
place them uh very nicely on the these
diagonals but uh obviously yeah it is
not enough uh
uh it should shouldn't be enough but the
d5 is definitely the uh top move by the
engine but magnus disagrees with that he
plays the d captures on c3 d captures on
c3 and now just queen to c7 so now uh
white might have to be a little bit
careful maybe we see some bishop b8
going after the h2 pawn but this is
would be very aggressive and it would
have to be a a setup that would uh allow
such a thing so here uh we have c4 also
queen the c7 attacks the c3 pawn so
nipple defenses we have c4
uh finally magnus castles and the bishop
to e3 now challenging the strong bishop
here and here magnus just trades if you
go bishop to b80s it looks very
aggressive but it's not really
especially in this position queen h5 for
example defends h2 and now you might
have some problems of your own
to worry about so instead of just bishop
captures on e3 we have knight captures
on e3 and then now we have b6 preparing
to then get to the light square bishop
uh after b6 will rook to c1 and now it's
uh well it could be very dangerous again
the queen is in the same file as the
rook if the position opens up so magnus
just plays a5 we have a3 and a captures
on b4 we have a captures on b4 and now
bishop to b7 you could also maybe go for
the very active rook to a2 but here it
uh just wouldn't be
all that active because after queen b3
you force the row back or even if black
forces this and this says okay my rook
is staying here we can still just push
it back bishop to b1 and if rook a3 then
let's say queen b2 and uh black really
doesn't have any threats here even
though he has a very nice queen rook
battery on the a file there is really
nothing there for example bishop to b7
it looks very nice rook after d1
white just doesn't care
so instead we have bishop to b7 magnus
nicely continues developing and now
queen to d2 now connecting the rooks
developing the queen queen to f4 by
magnus and although a very active uh
looking move with the queen this allows
nepo a very interesting setup he plays
rook f to d1 and now after rook f2 d8 as
this is a weak pawn uh
white has absolute control over the d5
square sorry about that arrow over the
d5 square you can see that once the
bishop moves the queen and the rook so
uh
two pawns uh knight rook and the queen
are controlling that that square so
black can't really hope to push d5 ever
uh so
it makes sense to defend the pawn we
have bishop to b1 that excellent square
as now we're opening up this and also
we're not allowing any future
infiltration with the rook uh we have h6
creating some breeding room for the king
from magnus and now nipple plays the
move that he planned and that is queen
to d4 and it's a beautiful move uh not
only because it attacks the b6 spawn but
also uh you would uh very gladly
give up a central pawn for this for
example let's say knight to g6 is played
uh we're going to play queen captures on
b6 and now even give up the central e4
pawn bishop captures bishop captures and
queen captures and i'll look at the
b-pawn the b-plane is marching forward
it's a pass pawn it would not be easy
to stop this pawn so magnus dislikes
this he shakes his head a little bit and
he brings the queen back to c7 so
f4 seems to be a bit of a
time waster uh and now nepal grabs more
space with e5 and now this is a terrible
terrible pawn the uh light square
bishop's diagonal opens up we can
threaten some very nasty ideas here uh
we're going to play b5 we're going to
take away the c6 square from carlson's
knight this is just a spectacular
position for white and also nipple is up
on time he's some 12 minutes on the
clock magnus eight and something minutes
on the clock uh and again it's uh it's a
difficult position to play what what you
probably should do is play knight to c6
but it's uh again hard to
to make such a move uh because after
knight to c6 and we're gonna play queen
e4 go after this h7 and now you have to
play queen captures on e5 allow this
queen infiltration uh and i mean there's
just no one who would allow this queen
h7 king f8 and now you're gonna play b5
with this tricky line knight d4 and now
we go back and uh threaten to pick up
the knight once the knight moves we're
going to trade here captures captures
and now trade the queens here queen d6
check queen captures rook captures and
the b6 pawn will fall
and this will be uh well very hard to
hold with the past b pawn so this is uh
better for white but it's uh the best
idea for black however impossible to
find with little time on the clock is in
a rapid game magnus goes for rook to a4
puts pressure on the b4 pawn and now
this gives
nipple a very very uh good move and that
is queen to b2 or queen to c3
so you move the queen defend the pawn
and then the game continues you're going
to bring your rook to d6 and really
leave black without a good moves but
here
nipple plays queen to h4 which seems
like a great idea you're threatening to
pick up the knight it's very hard to
move it um
if you defend it then you weaken the d7
pawn you are threatening some very nasty
ideas of maybe knight to g four night
capture serious sacrifice the night you
bring the rook into the game you check
made the black king so all of this is in
the air but it allows uh magnus for a
very very cool defensive idea so feel
free to pause the video and try to find
this a great defensive resource while i
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
because it's not really an easy move to
find and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it is not rook to e8
and it is not knight to c6 but those are
all uh good choices uh you know to think
about not to actually play them so
congratulations to everyone who found
king to f8 it's a a move that can easily
be missed because we usually don't move
our king around when there's so much
action on the board but here it's just
the absolute best move and magnus played
it just to give you an example of what
happens for example if we uh defend the
knight here then b5 is incredibly strong
just taking away the c6 square from the
knight here and once queen captures on
e5 we're gonna play rook captures on d7
and this is just bad the knight is
hanging the
the bishop is hanging of course the
knight is attacked twice so it would be
uh terrible to end up in this kind of a
position and uh instead of this knight
the c6 isn't all that much better
because we just play queen e4 and now
there's a big difference with the knight
being on e7 and the being on c6 because
now after queen captures on e5 we're
gonna play this check king to f8 and now
knight to f5 is just uh
guarding d7 square threatening this
checkmate uh how do you how do you
defend against uh such a movie you can
play g6 but then we play knight to d6
now we threaten this checkmate and now
after queen to g7 we finally trade and
pick up the free bishop on b7 so that
was also in the air so after queen h4
this is what nepo saw but he missed king
to have faded the move that magnus
played and now again uh it's uh anything
can happen uh situation so now uh nepo
doesn't really have any uh any ideas
that uh who were in the position uh you
know including b5 just stifling black's
position so now he goes for the all-out
attack he plays knight to g4 and okay
magnus starts to grabbing material rook
captures on b4 and now knight captures
an h6 and again it's incredibly
difficult to defend this unless you're
absolutely
absolutely sure of what you're doing so
feel free to pause the video and try to
find another winning move while i give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on not capturing
the knight and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is of course
rook cactus and b1 this bishop is uh
well just an essential attacker in in
every one of white's plans and it simply
has to be removed so congratulations to
everyone who found this uh to give you
an example if you capture the knight
we're gonna play queen captures on h6
and now okay if you go here then we just
deliver a check so that's pretty much it
knight has to block we pick up the
knight and so on uh but if uh king the
g8 then we have this beautiful bishop to
h7 check of course the king has to go to
h8 so king h8 and now this famous
checkmate bishop g6 a discovery king
here queen here king here and queen
captures on f7 checkmate so that's the
problem with accepting the knight right
away however after the move magnus
played simply everything works for black
so now you have to capture the rook
otherwise magnus will just grab more
material here so rook captures on b1 and
now knight to g6 uh freeing up the e7
square for the king and also forcing the
white queen to move away and you kind of
don't want to move the queen away from
the defense of the h6 square because you
have to capture there after why black
captures the knight here so queen g5 g
captures an h6 queen captures with check
and now king the e8 and here uh nepo is
in a pretty pretty bad position but of
course he will keep fighting he plays
rook to d6 now puts more pressure on b6
wants to put pressure on the bishop and
magnus just continues in the
cleanest way possible queen captures in
c4 we have rook d captures and b6
threatening the bishop here and now even
though c6 and d5 are perfect squares for
the bishop uh first you want to try and
uh stir some trouble with bishop to e4
we want to kick away the rook from b1
and of course if the rook moves then we
can maybe
deliver some back rank mate for the
moment the queen covers c1 so it's not
possible uh but you know it would be a
very scary so instead we have rook six
the b4 chasing away the queen queen to
e2 and now comes rook to c1
so we had to move the rook away from the
from the b1 square we have bishop to c6
and now would you play well it seems
that magnus defended and now it will be
only magnus who will go for the win here
but there is the simple matter of the
past h pawn so here nipple starts
pushing it h4
sorry about that
so uh starts pushing it with the h4 pawn
we have queen captures on e5 and now we
have h5 so the pawn is marching forward
but uh it's uh well uh it's not going to
be easy to promote it we have knights to
e7 and now comes rook to g4
so what can what can magnus do here to
to stop this from happening well he can
play knights to f5 but it's such an ugly
looking move that if you play knight's
f5 then you get rook to g8 to check king
the e7 and now queen to g5 check you
have to play f6 and now uh you have to
open up your position this much in order
to uh to play this for example queen g6
we're going to play rook captures on g8
queen captures and g8 now knight h6
attack the queen and after the queen
moves knight to f7 and now uh of course
we will win this position because after
h6 there's queen f4 for example and you
will you you will now lose the h1
because you have to save the rook so
after rook to g4 we have rook to a8 uh
and now uh nipple plays rook to g7 so
it's still not easy for magnus
to
you know figure out how to proceed here
but if you look at the position you will
play you will play d6 or d5 this is how
you have to play this but for some
reason magnus played king to d8 and uh
okay i haven't uh seen the interview uh
after the game so uh i guess it could be
maybe a muslim but i seriously doubt it
i think that magnus just forgot that the
rook here was actually attacking the f7
pawn so here nipple grabbed the f7 pawn
and now what you play all of a sudden uh
you came from a completely winning
position to a completely lost position
because how do you now how do you now
play now we have rook to a1 he wants to
get rid of the rook on c1 so rook
captures on a1 queen captures on a1 with
check we have king to h2 and now knight
to f5 chasing away the queen and here
nipple plays queen to g5 with check and
as both players are very low on time uh
of course mistakes will happen always
but queen to f4 was uh winning for
nipple uh point being that uh well what
do you play here uh after queen to b1 uh
you will simply start pushing the h pawn
and now after knight captures an h6 you
will capture it here
after queen to g5 check it's much
different because here magnus moves the
king to c7 and now it's uh it's very
much different h6 now there's queen to
e5 with check and this move would not be
possible if the queen was on was on f4
so here king h3 by nipple now comes
queen to a1 here magnus wants to deliver
this check queen to h1 with check so
queen the f4 check we have knight to d6
blocking and now rook to g7
uh if you're wondering why not push the
h7 pawn right away the well then you get
this queen to h1 check and the bishop
and queen are still attacking the g2
pawn so after queen blocks with queen to
h2 we're gonna capture with the bishop
here deliver check and once the king
moves there's this very nasty knight e4
check and now the king has no more
squares where um uh he can defend the
the queen on h2 and once the king moves
we're gonna play queen captures queen
and that's it so after knight to d6 we
rook to g7 and now queen to h1 with
check by magnus and now queen to h2 you
could also
maybe start marching with the king but
first we have queen to h2 queen to c1
and now king the g4 so nipple not ready
to call it a draw he will still try to
win this uh and now how do you continue
well there's always a bishop captures on
g2 it can definitely be played forcing
the queen to capture and then pick up
the h6 pawn this is one way to do it
magnus goes queen to c for check we have
queen to f4 blocking and now queen to e
to check king back to h3 and now we have
e5 attacking the queen here and now
queen to g4
again queen to g5 was uh
a much better square but it's so so uh
easy to miss this and both of them are
constantly very long time going down to
as much as 10 seconds on the clock uh so
here queen to g4 was played and now
queen captures on f2 by magnus with h7
ready to now bring another queen into
the game and now queen to e3 with check
we have king h2 queen to h6 with check
also one of the things that would not be
possible if the queen occupied this
diagonal uh queen to h3 and now we have
queen to f4 if you go for the rook of
course we just bring another queen into
the game so after queen h3 queen the f4
with check
rook the g3 now again trying to get the
queen into the game and now magnus just
plays knight to f7 and he will give up
the knight for the pawn and he will
start pushing the
the two connected past pawns so h8 queen
we have knight captures bishop uh queen
captures knight and now it's bishop
against the rook and the magnus is up uh
up upon
so how do you
play this with d5 magnus now starts
pushing his past d-pawn and the queen g7
check we have king to d6 queen g6 check
king to c5 and now queen to c2 with
check so will magnus go back and maybe
try and play it this way
no magnus well okay first he does go
back queen to d6 but now after queen to
c3 nepo is the one that is not ready to
call it a draw he wants to defend the
rook move the king so the rook can
finally move uh but now magnus starts
pushing d4 we have queen to a3 with
check king e6 now comes king g1 so the
rook can finally start checking the
black king now queen e4 forcing the rook
to always guard this g2 pawn saying that
you will have problems if if that
changes so here queen to c1 uh and now
okay uh also also putting pressure on
the bishop but now comes king to d6 uh
we have rook to g7 uh and now we have d3
magnus pushes the pawn here queen to a3
with check king to b5 and now queen to
a5 with check magnus marches forward
with the king king c4 queen to a2 with
check and now king to c3 the problem is
if you play king to d3 there's queen to
b to check and you have to go back
because if you go forward then queen to
f2 is checkmate so after queen a2 we
have king to c3 now comes queen to a3
check king to c to end queen to a to
check and again of course everyone
thought that we would just see a
repetition here but no king to d1 magnus
wants to play king e2 and the d2 hide
the king behind his own past d-pawn uh
and now nipple could try some checking
uh here with queen a1 queen v1 checks
but we have rook to f7 with the terrible
threat of rook to f1
and now there is only one move that
doesn't lose the game for magnus so feel
free to pause the video for the final
time and try to find the only move for
white uh or rather for black while i
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting that well
the pawns are just uh worth a rook and
for those who just want to enjoy the
show it is queen captures on g2 uh for
those of you who were thinking about the
d2 that loses to rook f1 check you have
to go king e2 now rook f2 check and now
just uh here and you will very quickly
lose the game so of course queen capture
sanji 2 is the only way to go even
though the white queen defends this
queen captures with bishop captures king
captures and now another super important
move
king to e2 if you think it's the same
king e2 or d2 you are very wrong because
if you play d2 first then king f2 we cut
off these two squares from the black
king and once you play king c2 to
promote your pawn then rook c7 check and
now you can't go back because then
you'll allow the white king to approach
so then we play king d3 but now rook d7
check king c2 and finally king e2 and
now both the white king and the rook
control the d1 square and of course
white wins this so after king captures
on e2 and g2 magnus plays the absolute
best king to e2 cutting off the white
king from helping out with the situation
and now the two connected past pawns are
just monsters however white can stop
this from being anything just to rook
after checking e3 and now rook to f3
with check and now if you don't want to
allow the white king
to go in you have to repeat king e2 rook
f2 check
king e3 rook f3 choking e2 and now rook
to have to check and he was in this
position finally on move 76 that nipple
and magnus agreed to a draw as there is
nothing more to be done here
so incredible incredible game especially
for for a rapid lasted 76 moves and so
many opportunities uh missed the end and
uh found but in the end i think the
the draw is uh more than a fair result
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it two more games to go we can
only hope that they will be this great
uh i would like to thank uh cypher kicks
uh leah joel bourne and james o'toole
john cousins and nikita nicolas for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon uh continuing the coverage of
the finals until it finishes uh so thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day